what you listening to son I don't think
you like it well why not I like this new
generation of music
[Music]
what's going on all you fellow swifties
and Believers and hip cool Zoomers I am
I'm not a Swifty I'm not not a huge
Taylor Swift fan but the people have
demanded that I bring my hip hop pop
music Maven Brilliance and wisdom to
Bear here on some new ditty from Taylor
Karma featuring ice spice I'm a huge ice
spice fan so that's great the condition
has left me cold do you please have
mercy
14 million views in nine days take it
away Taylor
comment is that girl like
he's talking
[Music]
of everyone you burn just to get there
it's coming back
[Music]
and I keep myself
put a pause there
I noticed something somewhat recently
and once you see it you can't really
unsee it and I'd always had a little bit
of an intuition about this but all pop
music is evil
I'm not saying there's no exception ever
but the modern popular music industry
this has just been evil and it refers to
evil and heretical and very often
diabolical Concepts not just Sam Smith
jiggling around with the devil hat on
but even this idea karma is my boyfriend
karma is a God I love Karma this kind of
a cult demonic sort of religious view
that says that Taylor does good stuff
and so she gets good stuff back and the
person she's castigating here does bad
stuff and so that person gets bad stuff
back so there's this heresy here which
is this idea that Taylor can earn her
own salvation I guess would be the
logical conclusion of that that she will
receive an endless cycle of good because
strictly of her good works not because
of her free wills cooperation with the
grace of God which is primary but just
because she does good stuff the reason
that bad stuff happens to you is because
you're a bad person it's a very corrupt
theology but very popular and like all
of pop music it just promotes these
views that are heretical and blasphemous
and sacrilegious right now head on over
to geniusell.com Knowles YT our friends
over Virginia cell sold out of their
Dark Spot Corrector and our listeners
have been begging begging on their knees
for a restock I've got great news just
in time for the summer it is back
geniusell's famous Dark Spot Corrector
has not won but three Cutting Edge
ingredients goes to work fast to Target
sunspots dark spots liver spots and even
old discoloration both on your face and
hands you can now enjoy your summer sun
Beach and barbecues without embarrassing
spots geniusell's most popular package
also features their summer Essentials
like the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed at how quickly you will
see the results or 100 of your money
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
knowlesyt right now to get your dark
spot corrector in the geniusell most
popular package that is geniusell.com
knowlesyt right now save over 70 70 off
geniuslaw's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last genusel.com
Knowles YT today
[Music]
and she never leaving you alone
put a pause there
this is the council the quote unquote
comfort that job's friends give to him
in the Book of Job job is an upright man
who follows the will of God and he's
very righteous and God allows the devil
to test his faith takes away job's house
and kills his whole family and takes
away all of his property and puts boils
all over his body and job's friends
quote unquote friends come to him and
they say joke you must be a really bad
guy the only reason that you would be
punished this way is because of how bad
you are and there's job and he's saying
I'm not bad I'm not doing bad stuff I'm
I'm righteous but
bad things happen to good people the
rain falls on the just and the unjust
alike this is a great consolation for
people who are suffering because we're
all going to suffer in life and the
suffering is sometimes a consequence of
your actions but sometimes it just
happens to you you could be the most
wonderful best person in the world and
you're going to suffer that's that's the
way the world works and if you believe
that bad stuff only happens to you if
you're a bad person that's going to lead
you into despair when that Misfortune
finally happens to you a really really
corrupt wicked wicked understanding of
the world keep going pretty light Flags
[Music]
you ain't gotta worry Karma never gets
lazy so I keep my head up my bread up I
won't let up I promise that you'll never
Endeavor with none ever ever
wow this sort of this ziggurat
cult imagery man
creepy
[Music]
what I learned from all those years
I'm still here and thriving entirely of
my own works not thanks to anybody else
or God's grace just me me me me me me
[Music]
mama takes all my friends to the summit
karma is the guy on the screen coming
straight home to me
[Music]
pause here
this also gets to another new agey idea
which is the idea of manifesting the
idea that if you insist upon something
through your will and psyche that the
Universe the created world will conform
to your demand which is obviously deeply
heretical because it suggests that you
are God that you are more powerful than
God that you can force the created world
to conform to your will through my own
actions I can get the guy on the screen
to come home to me I can get this app
and I can get that to happen because I
am I am a God okay
is
[Music]
karma is my boyfriend
I'm going to worship a god that is just
an expression of myself and my will
and me me me me
[Music]
pretty terrible
all right
[Music]